they are one of the planet's most
powerful predators
but also among its most vulnerable
despite their size and strength polar
bears have no defense when it comes to
climate change
with scientists now warning that melting
sea ice
could see most wiped out by the end of
the century
the problem is now they're having less
time to feed
and a longer time to wait till the ice
returns typically the ice melts in the
of early summer mid-summer and then
returns in the fall
and that period when the ice is absent
is getting ever longer
and the bears are facing that longer
period with
less fat on board polar bears rely on
sea ice to reach their prey
without it they're forced onto land
where there's not enough food to sustain
them
and such impressive beasts are rendered
helpless
by modeling how much energy they use
researchers at the university of toronto
worked out of polar bears survival
limits and when those would be reached
in different parts of the arctic
their bleak conclusion being that in
some areas that limit
has already been surpassed ultimately if
we really want to save polar bears
we need to revisit what people concluded
at the end of the paris agreement or the
paris conference in 2015
which was that we should be shooting to
hold world temperature rise
below 2 degrees celsius the scientists
say
aggressive cuts to greenhouse gas
emissions are needed to save this
species from extinction
with what they call a high emission
scenario resulting in the likely
collapse of all but a few polar bear
populations
it's estimated there are 26 000
currently living in one of the coldest
climates earth can offer
but if that disappears there's simply
nowhere left for them to go
iva bennett sky news